PRESENTER: Mr. Rubbia has
a distinguished high energy
physics career, so he
needs a little introduction
for any physicists
who are around here.
But, since we're having
this talk at the Media Lab,
we probably have a
more general crowd,
so I'll give a
quick introduction.
Even if you're not a
high energy physicist,
you've probably heard
about his famous work
at CERN in the early 1980s.
He's been a major innovator
behind the world's first proton
and deproton collider there,
the CERN P-bar-P collider.
There, he led the
UA1 experiment,
a very large at
that time physics
collaboration that discovered
there are quantum field
particles that mediate the weak
interaction, the Ws and the Z.
He won the Nobel
Prize in physics
for this work, shared with Simon
van der Meer, the accelerator
expert, in 1984.
He has been the Higgins
Professor of Physics at Harvard
during that time.
In the early '90s, he was the
director general of CERN--
played a prime role
in shaping the Large
Hadron Collider, the main
accelerator of this decade--
turning on in the middle
of the decade, we hope.
RUBBIA: Don't fall asleep.
PRESENTER: And he's active
in many projects since,
including the ICARUS--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER: --a
neutron [INAUDIBLE]
neutrino detector under the
Gran Sasso, outside of Rome,
and other things, including
the energy amplifier,
a novel and safe way of
producing nuclear energy
exploiting present-day
accelerator technologies,
and what he's going to
talk to us about today,
an extrapolation
of these concepts
to exciting new prospects
for nuclear rocketry.
Professor Rubbia.
RUBBIA: Thank you.
How do you turn this thing on?
It must be--
MODERATOR: [INAUDIBLE] switch.
RUBBIA: Just a simple switch!
That's it.
Amazing.
Things tend to be
complicated, around here.
Well, first of all, I don't
know what I'm doing here.
I don't know what you're
doing here, with me.
But I had a very nice
afternoon, looking at all many,
all different, crazy ideas--
and unthinkable ideas.
And so I feel rather prepared to
tell you about my ideas, which
are not that different
[INAUDIBLE] one
you are tossing around here.
Maybe something probably
will never happen,
it will never be realized,
but is worth trying.
I learned that 10% of your
ideas come true to reality.
Well, it's a good coefficient.
If we can do the same with this,
I think we'll be in good shape.
So anyway, the
problem is [INAUDIBLE]
about getting to Mars.
And connected with
it is the question
of whether nuclear power
could be used for that.
There is a group
of people in Europe
working quite hard on this.
It's about-- it's been growing.
At the beginning,
we had a few people.
Now it's [INAUDIBLE] to, oh,
I would say, 50, 60 people,
working on these
kind of concepts--
very general concepts.
They have no practical
connection, for the moment,
but they show the need
for some new ideas.
In fact, the need for new ideas
is pretty evident [INAUDIBLE]..
You know that the initial
description of going to Mars
has been done by von Braun,
in the famous early book which
he wrote in German when
he was a war prisoner.
And in that he described
the standard mechanism
to get there.
There are a lot of
difficulty, in doing this,
at the present moment.
Many people, including
especially NASA,
is trying to get there.
It's not very simple.
But eventually it
would seem to me
that this is one of the things
mankind would like to do.
Surely I will not be
there to see that,
but I think it's still
fun to think about it.
Now, if you wish to
do this kind of jump,
from going to the moon,
300,000 kilometers,
to going on to Mars,
where the round trip is
1 billion kilometers, you
have to somehow introduce
some substantial change.
You just cannot use the
same technology over again.
And the real question is,
can you use, or would you
like to use--
This projector's not
up to MIT standards.
Hmm?
It's totally out of focus.
And there's a lot of operations.
Okay.
I would say, up to
Harvard standards.
[LAUGH]
Anyway, so the question
is, do you have to use--
can you use-- nuclear power?
And I think you can
certainly convince yourself
nuclear power is
[INAUDIBLE] is interesting,
because it offers
you 3 million times
more specific energy than
the chemical reactions,
when you burn it all.
But energy's not the problem,
when, you travel in space.
What's important, in space
propulsion, is impulse,
is momentum, is speed.
And, in fact, there is
a famous rocket equation
which determines how much stuff
you can get there when you
start with this initial mass.
And this is the ratio between--
it's a very simple equation
which contains, here, the
sum of the speed that you
have to add to the
various operations
and divides up v, speed
of exhaust of your gas.
And that is essentially
fixed by chemical fuels which
can reach temperatures
of that order
and provide the specific impulse
of the order of 450 seconds.
I don't know whether you know
what specific impulse is.
The specific impulse is,
essentially, the amount of time
as measured in seconds,
the amount of time
over which a fuel will apply
a thrust equal to its weight.
So, if I have a kilogram
of a certain material,
and I burn it, that gives me
a kilogram for so much time.
And that time is the
impulse, specific impulse.
So, essentially, if you have
a kilogram of chemical fuel,
it provide you a kilogram
of thrust over 450 seconds.
And that is essentially
specific impulse,
which is proportional
to the speed of exhaust.
Now, the idea is, of
course, to go nuclear.
But the nuclear system is
limited in the temperature.
No, you cannot even get to
the temperature of the gas.
And because essentially
your material--
so your reactor is not standing
the high temperature itself.
And so you do with
a thing called
[INAUDIBLE] developed in Russia,
in the United States, 900
seconds.
But you do that essentially
not because you have a higher
temperature but simply
because you're using hydrogen.
And hydrogen has this
lower atomic number,
so molecules move
faster, and therefore
you get higher speed of exhaust.
Now, in other words, this is
a little bit the situation.
If you look at the
standard-- here
is the stagnation
temperature, temperature
which your system is operating.
Here is liquid
hydrogen and oxygen--
gets you an exhaust speed of
about 4 kilometers per second--
So, a specific
impulse about 450.
And we are talking about
machines, or, if you like,
systems, which should allow
you to get to temperatures
which are typical in the order
between 10,000 and 15,000
degrees.
This is hydrogen [INAUDIBLE]
and the specific impulses,
which are in the region
between 2,500 and maybe 4,000.
So we are talking about an
order-of-magnitude improvement
in the specific impulse,
respect to this system,
based with normal
chemical system.
Factor 10 in speed
means a factor of 100
in specific energy.
Let's be clear on that.
And that, of course, makes
the situation much easier
when you try to go to Mars.
In fact, the
most-used trajectory
is so-called
minimum-energy trajectory.
It's called the
Hohmann trajectory,
the one which was
proposed initially
by the original thing--
document-- book I was
telling you before.
The travel time is long.
It's 280 days it's essentially
freefall trajectory,
as you'll see in a minute.
However, if you get there and
then you want to come back,
you have to make sure that the
planets are in the right place.
And that means that you have to
add another 460 days residence.
So there's a fixed trajectory,
which you go for a year,
you stay there a
year and a half,
and then you come
back for a year.
And if you miss the
opportunity, of course,
things are not the right
place, and then you
don't get anywhere.
Now, if you want to get a
little faster with this,
you have to catch up on
the motion of the Earth.
And that in fact requires
much higher transfer speed.
And I will explain
you what I mean.
Now, let's look at
this curve here.
You see here you
have essentially
represented here the
[INAUDIBLE] of residence time.
And you have the 460, 640
days there, which correspond--
640 days, which
corresponds to the number
I gave you before, 540 days.
And then you see, here,
the various-- this
is the Hohmann trajectory.
And then you see, all
these lines are possible.
They're characterized, of
course, by faster transfer
velocity, but they give
you the same residence
time, which is of the
order of a couple of years.
If you want to go to a
much shorter time mission,
you have to make
conjunction trajectory.
In other words, you have to
run after the Earth, which
is escaping away from you.
And that implies that you have
to go to much faster speeds.
This is the area
which is permitted.
There is no other
way in between.
So, if you have
very slow motions,
5 kilometers per second, then
you will be forced to do that.
If you want to get to stay
there for [INAUDIBLE] less time,
you are obliged to go to
speeds, transfer speeds,
which are in fact quite large--
25, 30 kilometers per second.
Which implies, of course,
speeds of your ejected gas
[INAUDIBLE] order of
magnitude and therefore
require new methods.
We are talking
about, now, missions
of this type for the
manned CLIPPER missions.
And [INAUDIBLE] stay
there for the case
of transporting materials.
Now, let me show you briefly how
this mission can be realized.
The fast mission,
as I said, consists
of leaving the Earth here and
then running on this trajectory
and getting here, after
150 days, on Mars.
Then you stay on Mars as long
as you wish, from 0 to 100 days
or whatever is required.
And then you decide
to come back.
If you want to come
back, this time the Earth
has gone further, so you have
to catch up the Earth position.
So you have to run
much closer to the Sun
and then make a turn inwards.
And that allows you to get back
even something like, as I say,
another 179 days, but--
so, therefore, you can close
the whole thing in a year.
But it requires speeds of,
as I said, much higher.
This is for the people
which want to get there.
Now, if you want to
go and send equipment,
as you probably need
anyway, then you
can follow the Hohmann
trajectory, which
is the one represented here.
And you can see what Hohmann
trajectory is all about,
is half a circle.
You start here.
You go in 280 days
to Mars, 260 days.
Then you have to
stay all this time,
until such a time as the Earth
is in the right position.
And you leave here, and then you
go another Hohmann trajectory,
back 180 degrees [INAUDIBLE],,
and you hit the Earth
where it belongs.
That is, in fact,
the long-time trip.
Now, we are trying to study
all kinds of different missions
with the potential challenge
of this new engine, which
I'll describe in a minute.
Essentially, nuclear
power is going
[INAUDIBLE] to be used only
for transplanetary trip.
Classical method for
landing and takes-off,
so you use standard fuel to get
to orbit and then to come down.
Air braking is being
removed, at this level.
Air braking is an extremely
complicated procedure.
Imagine you arrive
on Mars and then you
have to get into sort of an
orbit which is slowing down
into the gas of Mars.
And the window is very narrow.
The difficulties of doing
that are considerable.
In fact, many of the problems
in getting on Mars material
come from that point.
We think that, with people,
you should avoid it.
The space station ALPHA
is used as a departure.
And [INAUDIBLE] mission
needs a reusable shuttle,
since many trips
are necessary and--
could be necessary.
And this device
will in fact operate
on a periodicity of Earth-Mars
orbits, which is 740 days.
And the question is,
the presence on Mars.
So the man is necessary for
the complexity of the task,
but the harsh environment
limits a stay to a short time.
It's inconceivable you can leave
a person for first time on Mars
one and a half years
eventually to make his own fuel
and come back and so forth.
So he has to be
able to go there,
to get the equipment going,
but then he has to come back.
And you need no sharp
departure window.
And then you have two kind
of missions-- the CLIPPER,
for fast manned
transit, and the TUG,
for material transportation,
which can be slow.
And the key, of course, all that
is a higher specific impulse.
Now, the present state
of nuclear propulsion
is not a very good state.
Essentially, Nerva is the design
which is now the best in town.
And it's an essentially
gas-core fast reactor.
The maximum temperature
is determined
by the temperature of this
uranium zirconium niobium
carbide, which has
to remain solid.
It runs at high
pressure, because the gas
has to go from here to there.
Here is the low temperature.
Here is 3,000 degrees,
so it has to warm up,
going through the
rods of the reactors--
so, high operating pressure.
The mass of the
fuel must be large.
It's 1 ton of highly
enriched uranium,
which is put into orbit in
order to get criticality.
But, however, during the
burning of all this system,
only 5 grams are burned.
The rest is-- it
just goes there.
You have to deliver--
get rid of it.
And there are particular--
many people getting
very nervous when
you put a ton of highly
enriched, bomb-grade uranium
on orbit.
Neutron leakage is very large--
10 to the 19
neutrons per second.
So it makes it very hard
for people to stay around.
It has to be shielded.
And even when it gets
shielded, it is not trivial.
You can avoid that
kind of irradiation
from [INAUDIBLE] these fluxes.
And the real problem
is essentially
that the fuel is, in fact, the
hottest part in the system.
Now, the basic idea is, can we
keep the fuel cold and the gas
hot?
It's what you would like to do.
The answer to that
is a very simple idea
which we are working
on, which is direct
heating by the
fission fragments.
Now, let me remind you
that 88% of nuclear energy
due to fission is carried by
two fission fragments, the rest
being additional
neutrons and gamma rays.
You have essentially
uranium 235.
You swallow a neutron.
Uranium 235 starts
to vibrate, to move.
It separates, like
two drops of water.
You get two little droplets.
They're both positively charged.
Therefore, they
repel each other.
No longer nuclear
forces are present,
because you have severed
the connection with the two.
And the 200 MeV you
recover is just simply
the coolant repulsion
of these two parts.
So two fission
fragments come off,
and they carry essentially 98%
of the total kinetic energy.
So why not use--
in addition, there are a
few gammas and neutrons,
but they carry only a few MeV.
So most of the energy is
carried by these two fission
fragments, which are back
to back, so to speak.
Now the question is, how can
you make use of that fission
fragment directly?
They have an enormous
enthalpy inside.
They represent tremendous
high temperature.
But you never see
that mini reactor,
because it stop
into the reactor.
Then you get warming
up of your material.
You don't get access
to that beauty
that nature is providing
you, there, with.
And so the question is,
can you use them directly
to heat up the gas?
The penetration range of
those fission fragments
is extremely short.
It's 10 microns, in the fuel.
And usually the
energy is converted
in heat inside the fuel.
And now the question-- can
you use directly these fission
fragments in order
to heat the gas?
That will, of course, give
you an enormous advantage,
as you'll see in a minute.
So we assume a very
thin fissile deposit.
Let's take a foil--
put on a foil a layer
of fissionable material.
And then make it thin enough so
that the fission fragment can
come out.
And then see what
happens, as a function
of the thickness of the foil.
Here you have a plot
which says 1 micron, 1
milligram per square
centimeter, 10 milligram
per square centimeters.
These foil are made out
of uranium or americium
or whatever you want.
And you see here the
energetic fraction
of the energy coming out.
Obviously you get 44%
if you had 0 thickness,
because 88% is fission fragment
and 44 are going one direction,
44 go to the other.
And then, when the thickness
becomes bigger, you get a loss.
For instance, if you
have 1-micron thickness,
you get 34% instead of 44%.
If you go to 3 microns
milligrams per square
centimeter, you get 24%.
Now, what are we
talking about, here?
We are talking about 1 milligram
per square centimeter, which
is 0.8 microns in
thickness, which
is 10 grams of a
meter-squared surface.
And we are talking about
1,100 atomic layers.
This is certainly not what
you'd call a nuclear fuel.
A nuclear fuel is a
very heavy material,
hundreds of tons of
stuff inside the system.
Here is rather a radioactive
source, if you like,
deposited on a thin layer.
Now, how do you get criticality?
Now, for that you need to
do some clever things, which
have to do with neutronics.
Let me anticipate
to you that I do
succeed in having criticality
with that little bit
of americium.
Now, let me be
clear about numbers.
If it take this americium,
which is the largest fission
cross-section known
around, 5,300 barns,
and you get the
neutron through that,
it is 1% probability
of interacting.
So, obviously, you
would like to have
100% probability of interacting,
to keep the reaction going.
And therefore you need about
a factor of 100 enhancement.
So can you enhance
the neutron flux,
with some kind of storage
[INAUDIBLE] device,
so that you can get the
neutrons over and over again
through your americium
foil and enhance,
this way, the
probability of fission?
The answer is yes.
Well, we have done lots of
experiment at CERN on that.
And, in fact, this
is not just a theory.
It's just an
experimental results.
The basic idea is that you
take a highly diffusing
but neutron-transparent
medium, and you let
in that thing a neutron travel.
Only elastic
cross-sections is there.
There is no inelasticity.
So this neutron moves
around inside this material,
in the same way that,
for instance, an electron
moves in an argon gas.
Well, the physical
reason's very similar.
Normally, you're talking about
nuclei which are double-magic.
We have here the great
experts of these things.
And a double-magic nucleus
is like a noble gas.
The shell is closed.
So, in the same way that
an electron cannot capture
in argon of helium, and it will
go around as a free electron
forever, here we are
talking about a nucleus.
And a neutron will not
capture the nucleus,
because the shell is closed.
And the cross-section
is very small,
and the result is, this
thing will just go around.
Look here-- there's
[INAUDIBLE] tortuous path
inside the highly
efficient medium.
This is computer
simulated, but the reality
is not any different.
The neutron is essentially
stored, stored not by,
like, a storage ring,
it's stored by diffusion.
It's a random process
but, effectively, it
keeps the neutrons together.
And that is, in fact,
has been showed,
that, in fact, 60-meters-long
path is wound in 35
centimeters, 1 foot in length.
And this is due to the fact
that this movement [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, in such a
storage medium-- so
you have a volume of this
type of high-purity graphite
or high-purity lead.
In that volume, you
have this phenomenon.
Such a storage medium,
because of multiple trials,
even a very tiny
amount of impurity
can absorb a significant
amount of capture elements.
Suppose you have a
ball full of water.
And you put there a little
bit of ink, just a little drop
of ink, the whole box will
have color of the ink,
even if the amount of
ink is infinitesimal.
Because the water is transparent
and is highly absorptive.
And sooner or later light
will find the molecule ink
and will send back the
color which you put in.
And same thing happens, here.
You have a very small amount of
impurities, inside this medium,
because you go around
and around and around,
over and over again, you will
eventually hit an impurity,
and then you'll get a factor,
because of this multiple trial
effect.
And therefore, 20 grams of
americium inside this box
will make it critical.
So now you can
make devices which
are critical with grams of
material, not kilograms.
Remember, in the
Nerva, you needed
one ton of highly fissile
bomb-grade uranium.
Here, with 20 grams of
americium, you're critical.
In this continued medium.
Now, of course, you don't
want to have continued medium.
You want to have, essentially,
the way to do this fission.
So we introduce a statement
which we call Hohlraum,
because it reminds
of a black body,
which is essentially a box
which [INAUDIBLE] high-purity
[INAUDIBLE] diffuser, on which
walls you put a thin layer--
1 micron, 1,000 molecules
layer of americium.
And then what happens--
neutrons will ping-pong
between the walls
of this container,
will traverse many
times the walls.
And [INAUDIBLE] enhance the
interaction probability,
as we will see in a
minute, about 100-fold.
And the ultra-thin fissile
layer requires a finite fission
probability, because of
these many traversals.
And the new fission produced
neutrons, of course,
will get thrown into the
box, and it will start again.
More precisely, we
assume the empty cavity
is covered with a layer.
The configuration is similar
to a black-body radiator.
And I'll remind you, the
black-body radiation in flux
is uniform independent
of the shape.
And the flux is
determined essentially
by the properties of the
material, not by the geometry.
The same thing will
also happen here.
And identifying independent
shape of the cavity, provided,
of course, it's well-behaved.
And therefore it doesn't
matter what the shape is.
You will get this result.
And also neutron temperature,
and therefore neutron energy,
will be relayed to the center
by the fuel but the quality
of the container.
So temperature will
be fully thermalized
with the temperature
of your container.
So you'll know very precisely
what the energy neutrons
you're dealing with.
And, of course, no
neutron will come out,
because, being a
black body, it will
contain the neutrons inside.
If they're inside,
they're not outside.
Now, the theory of enhancement
can be easily done.
I will not spend
much time with this.
It tells you that, if
you have any shape,
and you take the reflector
away, and then you put it back
and you leave the
same source, and you
ask to change enhancement of the
flux, because of the reflector
on, that enhancement factor is
equal to that expression which
is square root of elastic
scattered [INAUDIBLE] capture
cross-section of scattering.
Elastic is typical 10 barns.
In a capture cross cross-section
is order of millibarns.
So we are talking about a
ratio 10 to the 4, 10 to the 5,
between the two numbers.
And therefore, when you
take the square root,
you get good results.
And there are two parameters
which are important, here.
One is the diffusion
length, diffusion length,
which means the size of
your sphere of containment--
in other words, the
thickness of your walls
that you have to
use to do the job.
And the second one is
enhancement factor--
by how much you
increase the flux.
Now, if you get graphite, you
get 27 centimeters diffusion
length.
And you get 94 enhancement.
Beryllium will do fine, as well.
It is much smaller.
It's 12 centimeters, but your
enhancement factor only 73.
Lithium will be
completely transparent.
And liquid deuterium will give
an enormous advancement factor,
but you also have
very long length.
So you'll have to
build a huge device.
It's not practical.
And liquid hydrogen
is also excluded.
So, essentially,
you are ending up
with beryllium and
beryllium oxide and carbon
as interesting materials.
And then you try to calculate
with this system criticality.
And you do achieve
criticality rather rapidly.
Here is the thickness
of the carbon
wall, which is increased.
Sorry-- here.
I increase the thickness
of the carbon wall.
And then, here, I
put the k value--
which means k equal
1 means criticality,
means you get back as
many neutrons as you made.
And if I have a
layer of 1 milligram
per square centimeter,
1,100 layers,
you can see I get critical
with about 250 grams
per square centimeter, which
means 1 meter 20 of carbon.
It's a bit too much.
But if I go to 3
milligrams, you see
I'm already running
at 75 here, grams
per square centimeter, which
means about 35 centimeters,
which is that much.
This is 22 centimeters.
[INAUDIBLE] flying
over the Atlantic.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
22 centimeters.
And so it's a quite reasonably
small amount of reflector.
And beryllium oxide can
do it fine, even better.
And you can see that,
indeed, criticality
is obtained with
layers which are only
a few milligrams per
square centimeter.
So it is possible,
with this technology,
to make a critical reactor
which will operate with a very
small amount of material.
Remember, 1 milligram
a square centimeter
is 10 grams per square
meter of surface.
We are talking about
probably 100 square meters,
for this mission,
so we're talking
about between 5 and 10 kilograms
[INAUDIBLE] of americium
to burn.
Which is not very much.
In fact, americium has the same
properties as uranium 230--
plutonium 238, which is
used now on Cassini mission
and was on Voyager.
And usually you had more
than these kilograms on it.
So it's deja vu, as
one says in French.
Now, the problem is,
which fuel element you
like to use very quickly?
You have to have a high fission
probability, exceptionally long
lifetime, and
not-too-extravagant production
procedure.
Now, of course, americium
242m is an ideal device.
This is a cross-section.
Notice the cross-section drops,
when a temperature goes up.
This is the temperature of your
Hohlraum, 1,000 degrees 2,000
degrees.
So you're running here
in this region that
correspond to those energies.
Capture is very high, fission
very high, capture very small.
Big ratio between the two.
Now, if the other element
which is not so bad
is plutonium 239, which is
well-known as a resonance
here, at about 0.3,
0.24 electrovolts.
So that could be
used if you want
to make a container which had
high temperature, for instance
of the order of 3,000 degrees.
Then, in this case, you
could also use plutonium.
But you'll have problem of
temperature coefficient.
Here you have very nice negative
temperature coefficient,
because of this cross-section.
So plutonium is second choice.
americium is the first choice.
So I've done a very
complete burn-up
through a reactor of this type.
I'm not spending
time to discuss that.
Here is what happens
when you take
1.4 kilograms of that
americium and you burn it.
You can have a
fairly long burnup.
"Burnup" means megawatt
multiplied by day,
per kilogram.
Means one kilogram will
give you that many megawatt
per that many days.
So 1 kilogram,
here, will give you
400 megawatts for one day,
or 1 megawatt for 400 days,
which is much bigger than what
you get for a normal reactor.
A normal reactor, you
get a burnup of 20,
30, in those units.
Essentially comes from
the fact that the system
is much more efficient,
when it comes to burning.
For instance, here,
you can see, during
this 500-kilogram,
500-megawatt day per kilogram,
the americium coming down from
1.4 kilograms to about 0.7,
americium being burnt, americium
243 produced by the captures,
since there's a clean situation.
And here it stops, because
it gets below critical.
And so you can get a lot
of energy out of this.
You can burn about half.
Even more than half of
your americium can go.
And 3 milligram per
square centimeter layer
delivers that much power.
And, of course, if you have
a much longer operation,
you have to remake your layer.
It's a very thin layer.
It can be deposited
in some kind of a way.
This is-- the whole technology
has to be developed.
But obviously,
periodic refueling
may have to be
envisaged, eventually.
Now, how do you reduce the
americium very rapidly?
Well, essentially, you
start from americium 241,
which is naturally grown
in aged reactor-spent fuel.
Plutonium 241 has a
lifetime of 14 years
and goes into americium.
And then you make
a neutron capture.
And here is to explain how
you do the neutron capture.
And then you get
an extra neutron,
and you end up to 242m.
242-not-m is not stable.
And so the only thing
left is that one.
So let's come back to the
question of heating of the gas
with those fission fragments.
And so let's assume
we have a tube.
Typically, we are
talking about a tube
which is 2 and 1/2 meters long,
30 centimeter in diameter.
This is like a fuel
rod in a reactor,
only a fuel rod in a
reactor is full of material
and the cooling is outside.
Here, we are talking about
a fuel rod, which is empty.
And the fuel, instead of
being deposited as the volume,
is deposited to the
surface, inside.
And then we get gas in, and then
the gas go through this thing,
and it gets heated up.
Let's see what happens, here.
You have a tube, 30
centimeters in diameter--
in this particular
case, 2 meter 50 long.
There is a thin wall which is
cooled from liquid from outside
and produces 2 watts per
square centimeter of heat
and produces 3.95
megawatts of power.
This rod is immersed, as you
will see, in a lithium bath.
On this wall, there is
americium, 3 milligram
per square millimeter.
This total gram is [INAUDIBLE]
71 gram, so it's not very much.
And there is a little bit of
gas flowing through this system,
1.2 grams per second--
so, 58 microgram per
square centimeter.
So it's very slow-flow gas.
The whole damn thing is taking
1 gram of gas per second.
And the gas is
flowing very slowly.
It leaves the wall.
It departs from the wall,
and it [INAUDIBLE] warms up.
And when it comes down
here, you will see,
from exact calculation, there
is temperatures of the order
of 10,000, 15,000 degrees.
And, in fact, it's the wall
are cold, and the gas is hot.
So it's maintained.
This is my statement
maintained [INAUDIBLE]
foil reasonable temperature
cooling from outside the wall,
the sheet, the foil.
And the gas is
moving from the wall.
And when it gets
in, it gets hot.
And, by the time it
comes down there,
it goes between 10,000 and
15,000 degrees [INAUDIBLE]
which limits there are
and how can you get there.
Now, temperature limitation
due to mechanical strength
of nuclear fuel are removed,
because the fuel is cold
and the gas is hot.
Now, there is another--
there are several gifts
of nature in here,
which are worth reminding you.
First of all, the range of
the fission fragments exiting
from 3 milligram
material has been
calculated for the actual
Z and A distribution.
And it turns out that
the specific ionization
per unit of mass is, in
hydrogen, much greater than 1
in americium.
There is almost a factor 20
higher specific ionization loss
in hydrogen, with
respect to americium.
What's the cost of that?
The cost of that
is the following--
that ionization losses only work
when the particle traveling is
faster than the electron
bound in the atom.
And the sufficient fragment
is beta equal 0.04, 4%.
So many of the electrons
bound in the americium foil
have a speed which is higher
than the speed of the fission
fragments.
And therefore they are
essentially not participating
in the ionization loss.
If you take hydrogen, well,
the velocities is 1 over alpha,
and therefore it's much
smaller than the velocity
of the fission fragment, so
that you have high ionization
losses.
You can see here that the range
of these fission fragments
gives about 10 microns,
as I said, in americium,
but it's less than
0.5 micron in gas.
So you get an enhancement
of a factor 20
in ionization losses in the gas,
which is [INAUDIBLE] extremely
important.
And so even 1/2 a milligram
per square centimeter gas
will absorb the fission
fragment completely.
So you can operate
very low pressure.
Actually, in reality,
the fission fragments
go in all possible direction,
so the range is only
the upper limit to the travel.
So let me take two infinite
planes coated with americium,
defining a volume filled
with hydrogen gas.
So you have two planes, here.
And these two planes
are now filled with gas.
And the fission
fragment traversing it.
The thickness is 1/2 a
milligram per square centimeter,
so it's about 20
centimeter, 3 atmospheres,
just to get
[INAUDIBLE] understood.
Even at high temperature.
And then you have,
this is the kind
of heat produced by
the wall to the left.
This is the kind of heat
produced by the wall
to the right.
And when you put
them together, you
get a reasonably
flat distribution.
The important number here is
this very simple one dimension
of this drawing, which
in fact will be--
is worse than the case of
the tube, which I'll discuss
two dimension in a minute.
You get, with 400 watts per
square centimeter on this foil,
you get about half a
megawatt per gram in the gas.
Now, a megawatt
is enormous power.
A megawatt in a
gram is just putting
a megawatt on a mosquito.
And obviously, if you put
it a megawatt on a mosquito,
it will fry very rapidly.
And therefore the
idea is that you
can keep the foil under very
normal condition of a reactor
but get real hell
inside the gas.
As I said, you can get
a megawatt per gram
with hundreds of watt per
square centimeter on the wall.
Now, this whole thing is
played the following way.
Here you have, in this
curve, here, the watts--
unfortunately, it's hard to see.
I cannot even see, myself.
I wonder whether you can
read, yourself, over there.
Here you have one megawatt per
gram, 100 kilowatt per gram,
10 megawatts per gram.
And here you have
[INAUDIBLE] surface
power density watts
per square centimeter,
100 watts per square
centimeter, 400 watts
per square centimeter, 800
watts per square centimeter.
This is the kind of region which
normal reactor is operating.
And you can see that you
can go all the way up
to about 1 megawatt
per gram, in a gas,
with reasonable
heating on the walls.
And that is, of course,
transform into temperature,
through the enthalpy diagram
for hydrogen, where you have--
here, you have enthalpy
10 to the 5, 10 to the 6.
This is in joule per gram.
And you have temperature
[INAUDIBLE] 10
to the 3, 10 to the
4, 4 10 to the 4.
Now, you have to pay a little
attention to this curve.
Here, up to 3,000 degrees, the
enthalpy is rising linearly.
This is a perfect gas.
Enthalpy specific
heat is constant.
It's essentially a temperature
of a single hydrogen molecules.
At about 3,000 degrees,
the molecule disassociates,
becomes [INAUDIBLE].
Then you get the enthalpy
to do the destruction.
That is, like, a
chemical reaction.
You put energy in it;
eventually it will come back,
after you've done it.
And then you start
with another slope,
which is twice this
sharp, because you
have twice as many atoms there.
And therefore you have
a higher specific heat
contained for a given gas.
And then you get to
about 10,000 degrees.
And when you get to 10,000
degrees, the gas gets ionized.
And then you are getting the
13 electrovolts of ionization.
Remember, 10,000 degrees
kelvin is one electrovolt,
but here we are
talking about having
recovering something like of
the order of 10 electrovolts.
And therefore the enthalpy
grows tremendously,
even if the temperature
doesn't go very high.
And essentially,
you are now talking
about enthalpy,
joule over gram, is
going to power watts per
gram times dwell time,
time which you are
in the exposure,
time gas takes to come
out of the container.
Typically, we're talking
about of several seconds,
in this machine.
So we are talking about seconds,
multiply megawatt per gram,
equal to gigajoule per gram.
Gigajoules per
gram is right here.
So we're talking about
temperatures 10,000, 15,000
degrees.
And, when Nerva, you have
fast motion, short dwell,
here you have slow
motion, long dwell.
And this gives you
the impulse which you
can get with 10,000 degrees.
You have about 25 kilometers
a second exhaust speed
and about 3,000 in
specific impulse.
How much time do I have left?
MODERATOR: So 20 minutes.
RUBBIA: 20 minutes.
Okay, fine.
Now, then, to do
that more clearly,
we are talking about
parameters of this tube,
20-centimeter radius, 2
and 1/2 meters in length.
And we are talking about
1,000 degrees for the wall.
Final temperature in the
gas of 10,000 degrees.
And we are talking a very small
amount of gas coming through.
We are talking about
essentially speed
of the gas of 0.75
centimeter per second
in the beginning, 3 from 5 grams
per second through the system.
And this is the heating stage.
Then you have an expansion
cone, which brings you down
to about 25,000, 2,500
in specific impulse,
so 25,000 meter per second, and
with a thermodynamic efficiency
of about 17%.
Now, there is one
technical point
which I'd quickly
like to mention,
which is a substantial
limitation to this method,
to this system, which
are the radiative losses
of the gas which gets heated.
When that gas gets very
hot, it starts to radiate--
emits power away.
Eventually, if
the power radiated
is more than the fission power
coming in, you are in trouble.
Essentially, it's a lot of
work to calculate all this.
There are type of losses--
line, band, and continuum.
Now, remember,
[INAUDIBLE] we only
have atomic hydrogen.
Therefore, the molecular levels
are not there.
And essentially you're talking
about theoretical hydrogen
[INAUDIBLE] 1, 2
electrons [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE] then [INAUDIBLE]
we know all the numbers,
so all the calculation can
be done very precisely.
And it turns out that
the radiated power there
is essentially, the line
emission is quickly absorbed.
Essentially, the line looks
black because of the absorption
is, in fact, quite
strongly in the line.
And therefore, you don't have--
Essentially, it's like the sun.
When you look at
the sun, you see
the sun, the plasma of the sun.
You see the lines dark.
You don't see the
light coming out of it.
So there is no radiation
from the lines.
There is, however, a substantial
band emission, which is there.
It has been all calculated.
I'm not going to get
into details with this.
Essentially it turns
out that what happens
is that the light is
growing with the temperature
of the gas.
And this is frequency,
and this is the power,
after a certain finite distance.
And it's becoming
a lamp, a big lamp.
And here is the
surviving radiated power,
as a function of the
distance of the gas.
This is about 1 centimeter
of gas at 3 atmosphere.
So most of the light
emitted by the band
is absorbed immediately in
the region where it's emitted.
And therefore it contributes
only to heat conductivity.
But there is a
[INAUDIBLE] component,
which is this flat
line here, which
is, in fact, having
a very constant,
a very long attenuation path.
And this is the light you can
see on the walls, yourself.
This is all taken into
account in the calculation.
And essentially it tells
you that, up to about 10,000
or 12,000 degrees,
you can operate,
and above that you have a
problem of radiation which
you have to solve.
The other question
which is important
is the recombination
of the hydrogen.
The hydrogen is starting
from being-- well,
let me show you,
here, the curves,
which is probably the
best way of showing it.
The hydrogen starts
as a molecule.
This is this line, here,
is function of temperature.
This is logarithmic scale.
Very quickly becomes an atom.
And then, at about 10,000
degrees, it starts to ionize.
Here, for instance--
3 atmospheres.
Here 10,000 degrees
[INAUDIBLE] ionized.
And at 15,000 degrees,
it's about 50% ionized.
So essentially what
happens is that you
are dominated with atomic gas.
And above a certain
value, you're
also dominated by plasma which
is substantially ionized.
The plasma recombination
electron proton--
in other words, the
combination of the plasma--
it's a very fast
reaction, because it's
a gamma plus neutral hydrogen
equal to electron plus proton.
It's a perfectly
large cross-section.
The recombination molecule
to atom, it's very slow.
Remember, two atoms
cannot make a molecule,
because there is no momentum
energy conservation.
So a single collision
of two atoms
will not make a
molecule, because they
have to emit a gamma, and
the gamma is not there,
at those temperatures.
And therefore the
thing is metastable.
You remember the so-called
hydrogen torch, plasma torch,
in which you take atomic
molecular hydrogen
and you make it atomic
hydrogen, and then you
throw it on a wall.
And when it hits the wall,
it becomes molecular again,
because it finds recoil.
And therefore, it
gives you heat.
And, in fact, you can melt
a lot of stuff in this way.
Now, that is essentially what's
happening in our case, here.
However, as I showed at the
beginning, first of all,
the gas is essentially--
therefore, our gas is frozen.
In other words, we expect this
gas to come out essentially
as an atomic gas.
However, atomic gas means the
A is 1 instead of being 2.
And therefore you pick
up a square root of 2
in the number of the
speed of your gas.
And therefore, although you
will lose part of the energy
because you're dealing with an
atomic system rather than it
being a molecular system,
the effect on the specific
impulse-- as I showed in
the first transparency,
which I hope I can find
again, here-- is quite small,
essentially because of the fact
that the gas is reducing its A.
And so we have essentially--
This gas comes out very cold.
When it hit-- so the
problem of the funnel
is not a very important point.
Now, since we are
in computer science,
here, let me tell you
some computer simulation.
So I'll feel a little
bit more at home.
So what we've done-- we have
developed a lot of programs
which do the following.
This is doing
fluid-dynamics calculation.
This is making a
fission-fragment transport heat
release.
This is worrying about
radiative effects of the gas.
And this guy, here, is combining
the energy losses and energy
radiation to close the loop
with the program, which is
the program on fluid dynamics.
So this is a fluid
dynamics program.
Then it goes into a heating
from fission fragment
[INAUDIBLE] neutronics
providing the supply.
Radiation, you lose
power, you make power,
you take a power balance,
and you put it back,
and you make [INAUDIBLE]
current calculations.
And then we have done
several models, here,
with a typical 20-centimeter,
2 and 2/2 meters machine--
simulation, rather
sophisticated.
We have hydrogen inflow
at 100 kelvin, which is
in fact uniformly distributed.
And-- this thing
is really horrible.
And then you get essentially
various intensity of flow.
Let me show you some results.
Here is, we are increasing
the temperature of the heater.
This is half of the cylinder.
You can see that there's another
half coming on the other side.
So you start from
the wall, here.
When you move on, you
heat up the gas slowly,
until the gas gets very hot.
And then, eventually, down
here, the gas is the hottest.
And it comes out
from the funnel.
You see the same thing
here, case number 3,
which is the one we consider
the most appropriate.
And you do get about
10,000 degrees out of that.
And you do get essentially
all the gas is nicely hot,
at the end.
So the fluid dynamics works
extremely well in this story.
Actually, you can see,
here, global power, power,
the position and temperatures.
And you can see, in fact, that
these kind of calculations
are perfectly adequate.
So we have a good
fluid-dynamic model of this.
The heating process of the
fission fragment in the two
dimensions is quite remarkable.
Here, we had 200 watts per
square centimeter on the tube.
And here, we are collecting,
here, 900 watts per milligram.
So we are collecting
900 kilowatts--
so, 1 megawatt per
gram of the gas.
And you see here is the
radius of the container.
In the central part,
it's very uniform.
These two lines correspond
to the top and the bottom,
where there is no coverage,
on one hand, because you're
going out into the
nozzle, the top,
because there is
nothing on the top.
The americium is only the
positive of the sides.
If you were to
increase the pressure
from 2 atmospheres
to 12 atmospheres,
then you will observe this.
Your fission fragment
would just stop
before they get to the center,
and only the sides is heated.
A few more minutes left.
I can describe you, here, some
of the design consideration.
As I was saying,
this is the kind
of tubes we are talking about.
And then these many tubes
are inserted inside a box.
So let's look at this.
This is a realistic engine.
This will carry
emission, according
to what [INAUDIBLE] calculating,
over to Mars and back again,
in the way he was
describing it before.
It's made essentially
by a series of tubes,
2 and 1/2 meters long.
Those tubes are equivalent
to the fuel elements.
They have, on the bottom,
the nozzle, and therefore
they can be clamped on
a baseline, if you like.
They are immersed inside a
sea of lithium, liquid lithium
bath, which is the
coolant And these
works as a boiling-lithium
reactor, if you like.
The lithium is all around here.
And it touches the
outside of those tubes,
so that the outside wall is
cooled with this lithium.
And the lithium is
traveling all over, here.
There are control bars
coming into the Hohlraum,
so you take away the neutrons
to control the process.
The system is essentially
a lithium-cooled system.
You have lithium which boils.
Lithium becomes vapor.
The vapor lithium goes
over to the panels,
which are the cooling panels.
There it condenses again.
It becomes liquid and then is
recollected and put back again.
And so it operates at
constant temperature.
But there is the heating--
the fraction of
the heat which is
used by the boiled-off heat,
which is used for cooling.
These are the numbers
indicated here.
These we are talking about
thrust power of 30 megawatt.
Overall thrust efficient is 17%.
177 megawatts of
consumption, total.
Exhaust speed 35 kilometers
per hour, per second.
Propellant flow is 50 grams
of hydrogen per second.
The thrust is about
2,000 newtons.
The foil power density is 2
watts per square centimeters.
There are 88 square
meters of americium.
And this machine will run with
2.4 kilograms of americium--
so, very little.
And the refuel time
will be every nine days.
Every nine days, you
go in there [INAUDIBLE]
you just put your tubes
or whatever, to get going.
So we're talking about a
few kilograms of material.
And you can get nine days.
Over nine days, you
can get this power.
This is sufficient to
[INAUDIBLE] the mission.
I mean, you will
do these things,
refueling not during the
mission-- in the periods
in which you are recovering.
So it's quantized
in a proper way.
The other way of
doing it that would
be to do a tube-share
type of thing.
In other words, each tube
is blowing separately.
But that is a question
of the technical design.
Now, obviously, this is an idea.
As I said, all ideas have
a chance not to work.
This has certainly got a
high probability not to work.
But it's still fun,
worrying about.
First of all, the
behavior of the americium
under extensive exposure
to hydrogen is the problem.
The good news is that the
Nerva engine also has hydrogen
and also has a fuel.
It's not americium,
it's uranium,
but they're very
similar chemically.
Which is in contact with
hydrogen, at high temperature,
and it doesn't go away.
The bad news, of course,
is the position is thin.
In the case of Nerva, you've
got a piece of solid rock.
The other question is
radiative loss of the hot gas.
There's still some work to
do, experimental work to do.
Below 10,000 degrees, there
is essentially very little
or no radiation.
If you go [INAUDIBLE]
above that,
the calculation are one thing,
the experiments are the other.
You've got to do
something about that.
Now, hydrodynamic
calculation obviously
is the more important point.
And there we have questions
like transformation
in the nozzle from plasma
to the atom and the atom
to the molecule.
When it cools down, you have
to understand what it does.
It's frozen flow, et cetera.
And also other
possibilities are, instead
of using hydrogen you could
use any other material.
And one interesting
material to use,
it would be lithium hydrate.
Lithium hydrate is
a material which
is solid at 650 degrees,
boils, becomes liquid,
and then you can throw
it into the system.
It looks like a solid fuel
instead of being a liquid fuel,
from a practical point of view.
So you get less
thrust, but you do
have the advantage
not to go around
with enormous [INAUDIBLE].
And, eventually, in a
5- to 10-years period,
we'll have to do some testing.
So we are talking about
a test facility which
should be large enough to test
fully [INAUDIBLE] final tubes.
Now, in Italy, and in
particular also in America,
everywhere, every time
you say "a reactor,"
everybody gets
really up in arms,
says, my god, you don't want
to do it, et cetera, et cetera.
So we decided that
we could also do it
with a subcritical facility.
It can be done.
The whole round can be
fed with neutrons, also
from an accelerator.
And this type of thing
will allow you also
to produce americium,
after that.
And essentially it would allow
to us to get a faster track.
And the idea is to take
one of these tubes--
as I was indicating
you, 2 and 1/2 meters
long, and
40-centimeter diameter.
And they will give you
about a megawatt of power.
And exhaust speed will be
35 kilometers per second.
And you can put that in
the whole round, which
can be made, for instance,
with [INAUDIBLE] D2O.
Initially, eventually,
then you can go to lithium.
And the supplying
neutron will be
provided by an accelerator
which will give you
some neutrons in there.
And then you blow this
horn in this tube,
and then you collect the gas.
There's not much gas--
only 1.32 grams per second.
So you can pump it, you can
freeze it, and you can recycle.
So that could be a model,
taking one of these tubes
and make it work.
And then, if you understand
one of those tubes,
you could do more.
Now obviously, we were
talking about engines
capable of doing manned
mission, but obviously you
don't to have to do that.
You can use one tube
of smaller devices
to carry also
instrumented missions.
For instance, there are lots
of instrumented missions which
you could do with 10,
20 tons of initial load,
rather than using the
100, 150 tons which
are required to get on
to with a man on Mars.
And there is a lot kind
of interesting things,
like the story about Europa,
and so forth and so on.
I mean, in other words, get into
this thing with these devices.
Remember this thing
is very modest, here.
You only have 100 grams--
this device, 80
grams of americium
and 1.4 grams per second
of gas, but still gives you
about a megawatt
of thrust power.
So it's quite a device.
You don't have to go
to a gigantic device,
with a Superman getting
there, to start.
A thing like that is certainly
already interesting enough
for a device.
It's extremely simple.
There no moving parts.
There are no high pressures.
It's essentially a leaky tube
in which you put a little gas
and you get your fission
fragments into it.
So it looks like quite
cute thing to try.
Well, I'll finish with that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: We have
time for questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUBBIA: Not much.
The power going to the wall
is below 10,000 degrees.
It's very small.
AUDIENCE: And that includes
the radiator [INAUDIBLE]..
RUBBIA: Oh,
definitely, definitely.
It's all included.
I have a curve, here.
You see, I have a
curve, here, Arthur.
Here, we have a heating
power of 1.5 megawatts.
And then this is the power
going onto the walls,
integrated power
watts, and on the tube.
And you see that, if you
go to 10,000 degrees,
you're about 40 kilowatts.
So you get 40 kilo-- it's
a lamp of 40 kilowatts.
But the power of
the fission fragment
is 1 and 1/2 megawatts.
In fact, the amount
of power coming out
is only core-- only
[INAUDIBLE] regions.
See, it rises extremely
rapidly with temperature.
At 8,000 degrees,
there is nothing.
So only the last
little bit is emittive.
So you will see a very luminous
core, starting 8,000 degrees
and going up to 10,000.
That region, there,
will be quite a light.
But that volume is a small
fraction of the total,
because most of the
work which you do
you do at lower temperatures.
Because there you
pay the enthalpy
of separating the atom,
the molecule to the atom.
And that is where
most of the work is.
And therefore, there is
relatively little gas
which is very hot in it.
And that justifies this thing.
But this is a perfectly
legitimate and exact
calculation, using the correct
cross-section for hydrogen
and atomic modes, and
et cetera, et cetera,
with a complete
simulation of hydro,
et cetera, including all
kind of sophistications.
These require
parallel computing--
it's a big program--
takes 20, 30 hours to compute.
And I think, as far as
computing is concerned,
it is the state of the art.
Now, of course, reality
may be different.
AUDIENCE: How do
you throttle it?
RUBBIA: What?
AUDIENCE: How do you
throttle the engine?
Do you change just the gas flow?
Or do you--
RUBBIA: You-- first
of all, this thing
has very strong
negative coefficient,
temperature coefficient.
Therefore, by putting the
position of your control rods,
you somehow define
the temperature.
Define the temperature
of your device,
because, when it cools down, it
gets too high a cross-section,
and therefore k grows.
But then, when it gets hot, it
stops, et cetera, et cetera.
So essentially there
is a very, very strong
negative temperature
coefficient.
And indeed, you can
write the temperature
on your control rods.
And, depending how deeply
you're putting in and out,
you will fix the temperature
operation of the system.
So you can control
the amount of power.
Now, the second
variable you have
is the amount of gas you get in.
And now, if you put
in a lot of gas,
it will go in and out
rapidly, and therefore it
will change substantially
the operation.
So the second control
you have is that one.
With the two things, you
can, in fact, quite well
cover thrust factors
about factor 10.
However, when you
look at the mission,
you realize that this
kind of variable thrust
or variable in specific
impulse or whatever you want,
it's more a sophistication
for mathematicians
than the reality.
When you get there, you
go to a flat-on period.
And so I would expect the
95% to 99% of the time
the thing will run on and off.
What you do in the mission,
you start, first of all,
pushing it.
And then, when you get close to
Mars, you have to turn round,
and then you have to slow
down, to catch the system.
So the period in which
the engine is on is off.
But essentially you don't
have that much room for--
doesn't seem necessary to have
high sophistication, in the way
the engine is running.
You're not running
it downtown Boston.
[INAUDIBLE]
And this is only for the
transplanetary travel.
Then, when you want to--
then you stay on a--
you have essentially
two standby orbit.
One is the present
space station,
and the other one should
be identical, over Mars.
And then you have
transfer between the two.
And most of it is
reusable, by the way.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] couple
questions [INAUDIBLE]..
RUBBIA: "Convective transfer."
What do you mean?
Yes--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Ordinary process
of transferring heat
from a gas to a--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUBBIA: [INAUDIBLE] the
conductivity and radiation
conductivity are in the program.
But actually the
conductivity of gas, this
doesn't seem to be very
important, very strong.
What happens is, the gas
starts moving very slowly
from the wall and then moves
slowly towards the center,
warming up.
It takes about a second,
one second, to go from--
through the system.
So it's a very,
very slow motion.
And the corrections coming
from heat conductivity
are not that important.
In the long run,
they are irrelevant
except for the heat,
which it goes to the wall.
Because, if inside the gas
there is some heat exchange,
it doesn't matter.
The important thing
is that you deliver
the power inside the gas.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
was, the lithium cools the
wall, and who cools the lithium?
[INAUDIBLE]?
RUBBIA: Ah.
I have been a little bit too
quick, probably, on that,
but I am very happy
to come back to it.
What I was saying,
here, is that we
have here a liquid lithium
inside this device, which
is here.
And the lithium boils.
Volume of lithium
produces some, like in
a boiling-water reactor,
boiling-lithium reactor,
so you get vapor [INAUDIBLE].
The lithium vapor
is separated here.
Here, you separate
vapor from liquid.
The rest of the liquid comes
back and circulates again
into this, in this volume.
And the gas is sent to the
irradiation panels, which
are panels put all
around the engine,
and which they are operating
about 1,200 degrees.
So they give you about 300--
what is it, 300 kilowatts
per square meter,
or something like that.
So they're about 1,000 square
meters-- something like that.
And they are essentially
foils in which
the lithium enters as a gas.
It condenses on these tubes.
And then it comes back
in terms of liquid back.
The problem we
have seen there is
that meteorites may punch
a hole into these walls.
[LAUGHTER]
Ha.
It may happen.
And therefore, you have to have
a system in which the system is
sufficiently segmented.
Ideally, you have some kind
of wall valves or whatever,
which avoid that
kind of phenomenon.
But, at the temperature of 1,200
degrees, to get rid of the heat
is not an important problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
some electricity?
RUBBIA: What?
AUDIENCE: Don't you need some
electricity on a mission?
RUBBIA: Ah, of course that's--
I mean, this is--
absolutely right.
In this present approximation,
I'm saying, this heat is waste.
In reality, having 1,000
degrees temperature,
it's not a bad thing
to use, to do all kinds
of different things with it.
And therefore all the support,
the energy [INAUDIBLE],,
whatever, will all
be taken out of that.
And, by the way, there
are very nice devices
which are developed
apparently nowadays in Russia,
which are thermionic devices.
They're using a very
narrow gap, and they put
a thermionic emission effects.
And you make
[INAUDIBLE],, essentially.
You put gas in there, so
that you can get the high--
the space charge is eliminated.
And they take a lot of power,
[INAUDIBLE] those things.
This would be ideal
for this device.
You will have 1,000 degrees.
It is like a cathode
of a vacuum tube.
And it will emit electrons,
and those electron
will give you one volt potential
or something like that.
And then you will
be able to recover
a fraction of the energy
directly on the panels,
in form of secondary emission
thermionic type of devices.
There is plenty of
possibility using that heat.
It's not just garbage. .
There was some question there.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUBBIA: I couldn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: What would happen
to the fission fragment?
Would [INAUDIBLE]?
Or [INAUDIBLE] go with
the hydrogen gases?
RUBBIA: What is that?
AUDIENCE: What happens
to the fission fragment?
RUBBIA: Okay.
Very good question.
First of all, Professor
Kerman will tell me,
the fission fragment
are necessary,
because without fission fragment
there are no delayed neutrons.
And without delayed
neutrons, there
is no reactor, because
the reactors are prompt.
So a certain fraction
of the fission fragment
have to stay inside the system.
If you throw them all out,
you will have no possibility
of controlling the reactor.
Now, in reality,
as I said to you
about the 34% of the energy is,
in fact, carried from the gas
into the--
from the fission
fragment into the gas.
The remaining two thirds
of the fission fragments
are, in fact, staying
inside the material.
In principle, they should--
Half will stay, if they
foil is infinitely thin.
But if it's a little thicker,
you stop more of them.
So about half of the
fission fragments
will stay inside, implanted
inside, your foil,
just as they do in
a normally fuel.
In a normal fuel
reactor, they stay there,
and they eventually
get eliminated.
The other half will
go into the gas
and will obviously be
exhausted in the environment.
Now, obviously, that
is maybe a problem.
Indeed, it's not a
problem, because we
are talking about a relatively
small amount of fuel.
We are talking about a few
kilograms, over the billion
kilometers of transfer between
the Earth and Mars and return.
We are talking about a very
high speed of emission.
And the kind of radioactivity
garbage that there is in open
space, it's so large, anyway,
that these kind of fission
fragments-- nobody will even
be able to detect them--
[LAUGHTER]
--anyway.
So I don't think they
represent a problem.
By the way, also in Nerva
they are thrown out.
You know, this thing goes off
at 35 kilometers a second.
It's 100,000 kilometers an hour.
That's the speed at which
this thing comes out.
AUDIENCE: And the Martians
will be able to [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
RUBBIA: Right,
right, they will--
good.
There was another question?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
the main problems
with open-cycle systems
like this is not so much
that the fission fragments
contaminate whatever,
since we're talking about
space, but the fission
fragments actually lower the
specific impulse of the system.
RUBBIA: No, because
there are very few.
Because, you see, the
average temperature
of the gas, the average
temperature of the gas
is 10,000 degrees.
That means every atom
has 1 electrovolt.
The fission fragment
is providing 100 MeV.
Okay?
Takes a lot 1-electrovolt atoms
for 100 MeV kinetic energy.
There's a factor 10 to the 8.
So the one fission fragment,
one fission fragment will heat
[INAUDIBLE] hydrogen atoms--
and energy conservation.
And so you'll see that you have
1 electron volt outside there,
but indeed you have 10
to the 8 to start with.
So it's 10 to the 8 to
1, 10 to the 7 to 1--
something like that.
So there will be 1 in 10
to the 7, 1 in10 to the 8,
which will be a
fission fragment.
And that's a very small number.
It doesn't contribute.
There are ideas.
People have proposed to use
fission fragment directly
as a propulsion systems.
There are ideas in which you
take the fission fragment, take
the foil, don't put anything,
and let the fission fragment go
into space.
That will give you
a push, obviously.
The problem is that
the fission fragment
will have a very small
push, because they
have a very high speed.
And therefore they will give you
a very high specific impulse.
They will be ideal,
for instance,
to go to outside
the solar system.
If you wanted to
go to a nearby sun,
you'll need the
fission-fragment propulsion.
In this case, you will
not put the hydrogen.
You will just make
the system and let
the fission fragment come out.
They would come out with a speed
of 4% of the speed of light.
And therefore they
will be optimal
when the rocket will go
to 4% of speed of light.
So it will make, in 20 times,
20 times the light distance.
So you'll get there.
So, if you are five light
years, 5 times 20, in 100 years
you'll get to the
neighboring sun.
You can make a
mission of that type.
For that case, you will need
the fission fragment directly.
It would work the same way.
I mean, there's nothing
wrong with that.
You will not put
hydrogen-- let them out.
In fact, some other
people have even
thought about it, in
the past, [INAUDIBLE]
and so forth--
californium, and so forth.
That will be good if you were
to have much higher speeds.
But here you want to have
a relatively modest job.
You want to fill the gap
between normal chemical
and this kind of
vast propulsions.
So you need a lot of stuff,
with a relatively small speed,
to get sufficient thrust
with a modest power,
because the power
goes like MV squared.
The thrust goes MV.
So, if you have very high
speed, for a given power,
you get a little thrust.
But you get a
high-quality thrust.
So eventually you could do that.
You just run your
system with empty
and let those
fission fragment go.
And then you would get
very tiny, little thrust.
But they will go for--
will be on, even
if your spacecraft
gets speeds which are very close
to the one of speed of light.
It's somewhere in between that
and antimatter, if you like.
In my view, is-- but
it's very simple,
as an apparatus,
because you just
have a layer which emits
fission fragment in space.
So it can be very reliable.
You can think of having the damn
thing running for a long time.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you say about 1/2 to 2/3
of the fission fragments
stay in the wall.
But only about 3% of the
[INAUDIBLE] is facing the wall.
[INAUDIBLE]
RUBBIA: Who said that?
Who said that?
AUDIENCE: Well, there were 1
and 1/2 megawatt in the hydrogen
and [INAUDIBLE]--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUBBIA: --different power.
[INAUDIBLE] This is the
power which is coming back
because of radiation.
There was a question
Arthur Kerman had--
what happens of the light
emitted by the hot plasma--
how much there is
there, and how much
is the effect on the walls?
And that is a small effect.
AUDIENCE: Well, let me change
the question [INAUDIBLE]
how much is the total
amount of [INAUDIBLE]
on the walls [INAUDIBLE]?
RUBBIA: Well, I
was explaining you
that I am taking the
same kind of situation
as a normal reactor.
Let's take a normal reactor.
In a normal reactor,
you have fuel rods.
The fuel rod produces
about 200 or 300 watts
per square centimeter.
That rod is immersed
inside the sodium--
for instance, Superphénix--
or other liquid,
if you have different machines.
And this liquid
takes away the heat.
Correct?
Now, imagine that the
rod now is changed.
I remove the inside, the
fuel which is inside,
and I replace it
with an empty tube,
in which I put some
hydrogen-- that's my business.
And I transform
the fuel from being
solid all the way to the center
just to be on the periphery.
If I put that fuel
on the periphery,
my cooling will go
much better because I
will have no conductivity
problem inside the fuel,
itself, rod, but the amount
of power per unit of surface
is the same as the previous one.
So, in the same way I was
able to run a reactor,
with that power density,
I'll be able to run
this, quote-unquote,
"reactor" with empty rods.
I empty the rods.
I go from two-dimensional to
three-dimension to a surface.
Do you follow me?
So all the thermodynamics
is already solved,
by any ordinary reactor guide.
I would calculate my
own engine in such a way
as if I have no hydrogen--
[INAUDIBLE] turn off the
hydrogen, accidentally--
and [INAUDIBLE] all the power
goes to the fission fragment,
I will have enough
cooling to make it work,
as it is in a normal
reactor, where
all the power goes into fission
fragment and becomes heating.
So, you see, there
is a continuity
between building a reactor
and building this machine.
If any, when you
make this machine,
you are better off than
you are in a reactor.
What?
AUDIENCE: Do you have cooling
inside the [INAUDIBLE]??
RUBBIA: No, but I
forget about that.
I design a machine in such a way
that, even if there is no gas,
I don't want to have a meltdown.
And this is famous 200 watt
per square centimeters.
Which is the normal power
in Superphénix, in Phénix,
in other machines which
are run in the world.
Cooled with metal.
So, you know, it's like
you replace your rod
with an empty rod.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in
the end, half of the power
has to be radiated
away [INAUDIBLE]
RUBBIA: I am designing
a machine in such a way
that the full power
can be dissipated away
and still the machine works.
Because if I switch
off the hydrogen,
then all the fission
fragment will return--
inside the layer,
on the other side.
And I have to be
prepared for that.
AUDIENCE: I think I see
where the confusion is,
in that you're talking
about fission fragments
and saying if one
third of them heats
the gas to these
enormous energies,
then the other two
thirds should be
heating the walls of these
enormous temperatures, as well.
Is that what you're saying?
RUBBIA: No, no.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUBBIA: But the
gas is-- the point
is, they stop in the gas
20 times more efficiently.
The point is that the
gas is very viscous,
is very effective in
stopping the fission
fragments, while
the other is not.
Do you see the
difference in range?
It's a factor 20 to 1.
So the power density in
the gas is very high.
This way, you get
megawatts per gram,
with 200 watts per square
centimeter on the surface.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: What are
the typical residence
times for the neutrons
in the diffractor?
RUBBIA: Can't hear you.
AUDIENCE: What are
the typical residence
times for the neutrons in the
diffractive medium, outside?
RUBBIA: In this thing, they last
about 30 or 50 milliseconds.
They are acoustic.
You could hear them
coming and going.
You know, they just go for--
you know, they go about 300
or 400 times, back and forth.
They're traveling a
kilometer per second.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
thermal speed.
So, 1,000 meters
per second-- sorry,
1,000 meters per second-- right?
Is the speed of neutrons.
Right?
They go 3 meters, each crossing.
So 100 times is 300 meters.
So 1,000 meters per second, 300
meters, is about 0.3 seconds.
So those neutrons stay forever.
They stay for a--
You could hear it!
You get the neutron in, and
when it comes out it say
"bingo-bingo."
You can hear the two
[INAUDIBLE] sounds.
You should be able to send
two sounds separately,
like in sonar.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
RUBBIA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
review the [INAUDIBLE]
slightly [INAUDIBLE] mission
profile, given this engine.
Are you still talking
about [INAUDIBLE]??
RUBBIA: No.
[INAUDIBLE] This
is a good question.
I think it's important
it's clarified.
I don't believe you can send a
man on the Hohmann trajectory.
One year to get there, 700 day--
640 days to wait
for the good time.
And then another
year to come back.
Besides, if he's American every
year he has to pay his taxes.
That's the law.
[LAUGHTER]
So he needs a special waiver.
So anyway, so evidently
this is not possible.
In the mission 3.0 of NASA,
one assumes that you get there
and you manufacture
your own fuel there.
So you get there, for the
first time in your life,
in conditions which
are extremely harsh.
You stay there for 600 days,
which is two years, and--
in little boxes.
And then you have to
make your own fuel.
And if you need an extra
gasket, spare parts
will be hard to find.
[LAUGHTER]
Correct?
And then you come back.
You stay another--
and by the way,
also, there's a
fundamental point
which has to do with radiation.
We have calculated the
amount of radiation dose
that you get by staying
there, and it's very large.
The fact that Mars has a
very thin amount of air,
it enhances the
radiation, because you get
a maximum of the cosmic rays.
And even if you go
underground, you
have to go underground
something like 5, 10 meters
before you can get rid
of the whole thing.
And, in fact, you get
skyshine from the soil.
You sit there.
All these cosmic rays
go inside the soil,
and then they come back--
nice neutrons, which
you get into your body
and so forth and so on.
The dose, it's enormous.
It's larger than the
Chernobyl firemen.
So the risk of a very long trip
is primarily radiation hazard,
in my view.
And it's my view, it's
very much of the limit
of what you can accept.
50% survival probability,
stuff like that.
Already on the moon
there was a lot
of radiation given
to those astronauts.
People don't underline that,
but that was a very short trip.
Here, we're talking about
three years, four years,
five years away from home.
Now, obviously, the question is,
do you need a man over there?
In my view, for many things
you don't need a man.
You can send a test,
a device, et cetera.
But those machinery
will be so complicated
that you need somebody
to go and fix them.
Look at the Hubble telescope.
If you don't send the guy up
there to change the window,
it will not be
possible to repair it.
And similar thing will
happen also over to Mars.
So Mars as a planet is a
very complicated thing.
You have to do an enormous
amount of exploration,
to do that, and lots of
experiments, stable studies,
and not just go and
touch, touch and go.
It's a real planet with a
complicated story and so forth
and so on, et cetera.
So you will have a lot
of equipment there, which
will run more or
less automatically
but will need now and then a
man to fix it, to install it,
to modify it, et cetera.
So you need presence of man in
space but not total presence--
only in a short period of time.
So we are devising a mission
in which you go there
on a very short track.
You go there in 100, 150 days.
You stay there for a
limited period time,
with no time window.
So, if today you cannot do
it, if it's a dust tempest
or whatever, you can
go back tomorrow.
And then you come back.
And then this you could
do with the periodicity
which is 740 days, which is the
superperiodicity of the system.
In the meantime,
you send the cargo,
which can take all
the time to get there,
with a lot of stuff, a lot of
equipment, which you install
and you operate.
So the idea is that you have
cargoes which bring the largest
amount of material [INAUDIBLE]
the specific impulse is useful,
because it reduces the--
increases the efficiency
of the payload.
And you get there with
a substantial payload,
and then you leave it there.
Essentially, it's dead.
It never comes back.
The engine, the TUG,
comes back empty,
and the rest stays there.
And then you send
a human mission
periodically to update the
system, to improve the system,
to collect the data,
to fix whatever
has to be fixed, to
take the decision,
but on a short period of time.
And that implies about 1,500
days to stay there and 150 days
to come back and forth.
This is possible, with
these kind of engines--
is impossible with the chemical.
That from Braun
is already proven.
It's marginally possible--
probably impossible-- as well,
also, with Nerva's.
The other problem
is also the question
of putting in space an amount
of fissionable material.
Here, americium is very similar
to plutonium 238, as I said.
Americium is one third of the
toxicity of plutonium 238,
roughly the same lifetime.
And so we are bringing
in a hazard which
is comparable to this
generator already used,
to put a ton of highly
fissile material in orbit.
Well, there are presumably
a reactor in orbit,
but they belong to security--
you know, classified activities
of some unspecified country.
But, in practice, if you
make a thing like this,
you can go with a ton of
uranium and hope the people will
let you get away with it.
MODERATOR: I'd love to
entertain more questions,
but we have to close
things down [INAUDIBLE]..
First, let's thank
our speaker again.
RUBBIA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]